partner are if you've got a new product
that's different that's unique and
you're trying to get it to market the
fastest and most effective way to do it
is to partner up and that's fine people
who have a similar interest to you they
believe in what you're doing and they
have a community that they can help
promote your product or service to this
isn't partner up and bring on partners
in your business I don't need you to
give up an equity position in your
company it's instead finding people who
have common ground with you who are
established in the market who can help
introduce you to their customers so this
came as a result of one of my newsletter
readers Michael Michaels from Kenya I
mean Michaels is great entrepreneurs
from Kenya writing in michael has an
organic pig farm and he's going up
against big companies with deep pockets
or spend a lot of money on advertising
who are not doing organic and he wants
to know how do I get the word out about
my organic product and make some money
doing this so you got to understand it's
never gonna be going up against the big
guys and fighting them on advertising
right they will always outspend you
advertising is it is being reduced every
year and its effectiveness anyways
that's not the fight you want to fight
you will never beat them going
head-to-head in advertising the way to
beat them the way to get your product to
market is to find other people who care
about organic stuff you look for
wholesalers you look for distributors
you look for retailers you look for
stores you look for people who are
already selling this stuff not pork but
other stuff right there might be selling
organic chicken they might be selling
organic beef they may not be selling
meat at all but they're telling other
organic products it might be a health
and wellness store and this is your
chance for them to have their first meet
line right people who are already of the
same mindset because if you walk into a
traditional stores that we don't need
organic and that's a reaction that's
going to be a hard sale but people who
already believe on organic stuff they're
going to want your product those are the
people you need to talk to and
up with I'd also partner up with people
who have influence who may not have a
store may not have a business but you
look at reporters you look at bloggers
you look at people who have an influence
in your market right so what reporters
can you talk to what bloggers can you
talk to what social media people can you
talk to who have influence in your local
area where they say this is a great
product to check out people are going to
listen partner up with those people
because it's not going to happen you
going door to door knocking on people's
doors and saying hey I've got organic
pork you guys want to buy some that's
not the way to build this thing up it's
going to take too long you're going to
run out of time and money you have to
find people who already have the
connection to your market and find a way
to partner up it's the fastest and most
effective way to grow a new business
believe so those are watching like the
video thumbs up below let me know what
you think your comments means so much to
me i love reading them every day leave a
comment below ask me a question below
and you can click on my face to see more
videos and subscribe to the channel
thank you so much i'll see you soon